hoy se rumora que lionel messi le habría
dicho a su club ya no quiero seguir es
la bomba deportiva de este momento sin
duda alguna según confirman los
principales medios españoles
lionel mesi comunicó la directiva del
barça que quiere marcharse del club en
este mismo mercado de fichajes y además
gratis es una información anticipada por
los compañeros de teis esports y que ha
desatado una verdadera tormenta sobre el
conjunto culé la situación de acuerdo
con estos reportes es la siguiente messi
entiende que aún puede atenerse a la
cláusula de su contrato que expiró el 10
de junio y que le permite marcharse del
barcelona de manera unilateral y
crearles a otro club dada las
condiciones atípicas de esta temporada
por la pandemia sin embargo el equipo
entiende que al haber pasado esa fecha
el argentino fue renovado
automáticamente hasta 2021 y el que
quiere llevárselo tiene que pagar 700
millones de euros de su cláusula mes y
tiene de 33 años y lleva desde los 13 en
el barcelona escuadra con la que ha
ganado 10 ligas y cuatro champions
league sin embargo el barça tocó fondo
este año tras caer 8 a 2 contra el bar
zela contra bayern de múnich en cuartos
de final de la liga de campeones en
medio de toda esta especulación en
tuiteó carles puyol
del barcelona y leyenda de los culés
respeto y admiración leo todo mi apoyo
fue lo que dijo incluso se pronunció
quinto el presidente catalán que le
expresó en catalán a messi que cataluña
siempre será su casa y le dijo que no lo
olvidarán mientras tanto esto pasaba en
las calles de barcelona
[Aplausos]
de ser lo que gritaba un pequeño grupo
de personas a las afueras del camp nou
el estadio del barcelona algunos de
ellos también pedían la dimisión del
presidente del club de maría aval con
marc es más que un rumor entonces juan
esta noticia y estaremos actualizando
nos contigo precisamente en la sección
deportiva